Dark has come to an end and if you're
like me your brain has exploded from
watching the latest season so I'm the
masochist and thought it would be fun to
put some of the biggest events of the
entire three seasons starting from the
early 1800s to mid 2000s I was hesitant
to call this a chronological timeline
since technically some of the events
that occur in the 2000s actually occur
before events in the 1920s that's where
things start to get complicated so to
make things easy we're just gonna start
from 1822 and work our way up and I'll
provide additional context for some of
the more WTF moments just note these are
events I deemed to be important and for
reasons of brevity a lot is left out so
if you thought I should have added
something please don't hesitate to leave
a comment below but before we get
started make sure to LIKE and subscribe
and check out my season 3 ending explain
video which will definitely help fill in
some of the gaps the furthest back we go
is September 23rd 1822 Gustav townhouses
with his son Leopold and teaches him
about the possibility to bring back the
dead
you see Gustav here lost his wife and
believes time travel may be the solution
to bringing her back this obsession will
work its way to Leopold who when he
grows up allows Jonas to use his shop to
construct a time machine for those with
keen eyes in episode 4 of season 3 you
can even make out the Year 1822 written
on the wall of the future bunker which
is all the way in the year 2050 two of
the alternate timeline but we are just
getting started
fast-forward to 1888 where Jonas and the
teens from the end of season 2 have been
transported after using the time
apparatus just before the apocalypse
they will be stuck here for quite some
time and in September of this year
Leopold is killed by a man known as the
unknown who we know to be Jonas and
Marta's son Leopold was on his way to
send a telegram telling the world that
time travel is possible
two years later Jonas and the teens are
still working on the time machine but
this is also where Sylvia has been sent
back - all the way from the year 2050 3
by Adam Silva and bartosh will later
fall in love and in 1904 they give birth
to a boy named
No hanno is an anagram for Noah
unfortunately six years later seal juh
will die in childbirth while having
Agnes in 1911 hannah is brought to Adam
by Eve causing him to later kill his own
mother because she's not supposed to be
in this time period and it might screw
up his plan of cutting and destroying
the knot around 1920 is when Aegon
Tiedemann is born and a year later in
June of 1921 Jung Noah and an older
bartosh work on the cave passage but
young Noah kills him at Adams orders
because bartosh has started to lose his
faith in Adams plan at this point Noah
is fully brainwashed by Adams plans and
doesn't yet know that bartosh is his
father and that kind of [ __ ] happens a
lot in this show just wait till we get
to the 80s two days later on June 23rd
Jonas wakes up in a wheat field after
having traveled through the god particle
from the year twenty fifty three here he
meets young Noah and Agnes and a day
later he's taken to Adam who he finds
out is his older self on the 27th no
attempts to kill Adam after finding out
his real plan he learned this after
collecting the final pages of the
triquetra book which he got by killing
Claudia in the future when he tries to
shoot Adam the gun doesn't work fate
will not allow Adam to be killed here
agnes takes the gun from noah and ends
up killing him her own brother because
she so firmly believes in Adams plan and
wants to be a member of SiC Buddhists
jumping all the way to 1942 we have the
birth of Claudia Tiedemann and a year
later Helga dopler in November of
nineteen fifty three adult Helga has
traveled from the 80's to dispose of the
bodies of Erik Obon Dorf and Yasin who
were taken from the year 2019 this is
also where Ulrich travels back in time
and attempts to kill young Helga
believing that he kills him he'll never
grow up to kidnap his missing son Mikkel
at the same time Bern doppler holds an
investor's meeting for the future wind
and nuclear plant and a day later on
November 11th Ulrich is arrested by Egon
on suspicion that he killed those two
boys found in the sandpit on the same
date old claudia has traveled back in
time to visit HG tan house and give him
the blueprint
for the apparatus machine seven months
later in June of 1954 old Claudia will
bury her time apparatus machine so that
it can be dug up in 1987 by her younger
self
she also visits her father Egan and
apologizes to him he of course thinks
she's a nut job but she wanted to
apologize because in the future she'll
end up killing him old Claudia also ends
up giving tan house his own book which
explains time theory a book he hasn't
yet written this was a present given to
Claudia in the 80s by Helga Noah ends up
killing Claudia to retrieve the missing
notebook pages and finds out that
Charlotte is his daughter Hannah arrives
on June 26 having stolen a middle-aged
Jonah's time apparatus in the year 2020
he or she finds Ulrich in prison but
leaves him there after she finds out
he's still in love with Katarina talk
about stone cold this is also where she
begins her affair with egg on Tiedemann
three months later in September she
finds out she's pregnant with his baby a
baby which will eventually become seal
jaw this is also the time where the
unknown threatens to kill the mayor of
windin unless he grants the permit to
build the nuclear plant after finding
out egg on is cheating on her Doris
divorces him and Hannah decides not to
go through with an abortion but we do
see a young Helen Abers Caterina's
mother go through with one these
operations are performed by mrs. open
door for the mother of jurgen open door
it's pretty quiet from 1954 to 1970 in
1970 we see the births of Ulrich Nielson
and Katarina Albers a year later in
August of 71
Regina Tiedemann is born and in the
origin world timeline we have arguably
the most important event of the entire
series the event that started everything
August 11th 1971 is when H G townhouses
son and daughter-in-law are killed in a
car accident spurring him to build a
time machine which will result in the
splitting of the world into two
realities this is also the year yonus
and Marta travelled to and successfully
stopped the crash from happening 1972
sees the birth of haddock on Walt
Jonas's mother and two years later in 74
town house begins his work on the time
machine in the bunker it takes him 12
years but tan house successfully
completes the Machine and on June 21st
1986
he rips the world into two realities on
October 9th 1986
Mads Nielsen Ulrich's brother goes
missing he was kidnapped by Helga next
month Mikkel arrives in this world
having traveled from 2019 this is also
where Claudia learns of the barrels of
nuclear waste stashed in the wind and
caves on November 7th Mikkel and Hannah
meet for the first time they'll
eventually marry and have yonis jonas
coming from the Year 2019 travels to
1986 and actually sees Mikkel but ends
up not bringing him back to the present
because if he did that that would mean
yonus would never exist on November 11th
a young Boris nee wold also known as
Alexander Tiedemann arrives in windin on
the run from police
he'll later get a job at the nuclear
plant welding the door that connects the
cave to the plant that contains all the
toxic waste he'll fall in love with
regina and later become the head of the
plant the onus is captured by Noah and
Helga and locked in the bunker where
he's visited by his older self who plans
to fix everything by activating the
apparatus and closing the wormhole this
as we find out does not work and only
ends up with Jonas being transported to
the year 2050 to 1987 sees their rival
of Peter Doppler in windin who will end
up marrying Charlotte old Egan's
investigation into the disappearance of
Mads Nielsen leads him to this psych
ward where he eventually finds out that
old Ulrich is the same person as a teen
Ulrich after Egon brings him a picture
of Mikkel who is alive in this year
Ulrich escapes from the psych ward where
he's later caught by police at the exact
same moment that teens from 2020 have
transported they're using Bar Tasha's
time apparatus and apparatus he got from
Noah who he's working with the next day
Egon and Claudia get in a fight and
Claudia accidentally ends up killing him
when he's knocked over into the counter
three months later in September of 1987
the unknown kill old burned oppler to
get access to the master key of the
nuclear power plant Katarina shows up
here having gone through the passage at
the end of season 2 and is in search of
Ulrich and Mikkel she winds up finding
old Ulrich and vows to break him out of
the psych ward the only thing she needs
is a keycard and who happens to have one
her own mother who works at the ward she
holds her mother at knifepoint
but ends up getting killed by her that
seems to be a theme in the show in
August of 1993 Regina and Alexander Mary
and the next year so do auric and
Katerina nine years later roughly around
2003 we have the births of Jonas Marta
bartosh Magnus and Francesca with Mikkel
being born in Oh 8 and Elizabeth dopler
in 2011 June 20th is the day before
adult mikkel suicide yonis kisses Marta
at the lake and Ulrich and Hanna kiss
perhaps starting their affair which is a
big plot point of season 1 it's here we
learn Michael's suicide was a sacrifice
because if he doesn't kill himself he
can't set yonus on the path that will
eventually save everyone the next day on
June 21st we get the first scene of
episode 1 season one where Mikkel hangs
himself hopping over to the alternate
timeline on September 2nd we see Regina
Tiedemann has died and back to the
normal timeline it's on October 22nd
that Erik Oberndorf the first of the
missing women children is kidnapped by
Helga November 4th as the day young
nickel disappears having been
transported to 1986 in the alternate
timeline on the same day Jonas is taken
here after being saved by Marta at the
end of season 2 it's on this state he
also meets Eve the counterpart to Adam
who is actually just old Marta on the
fifth the stranger arrives in windin who
we know is older yonus this is also an
Alexander now the head of the power
plant orders the barrels of toxic waste
removed since the police may be
investigating the caves as a result of
the missing children November 6 the
stranger marks Jonases map the onus will
use this marking to find the portal that
eventually takes him to 86 where he'll
find out that Mikkel is still alive and
is his father in the alternate timeline
on this day onus and alternate Marta
make love which will result in Marta
becoming pregnant and later giving birth
to the unknown and shortly after this
lovefest Winona Springs Marta to Eve
he's shot by another version of Marta
but we'll get to how this comes about in
a bit still in the alternate timeline
Ulrich attempts to kill adult Helga but
he himself is killed in the process on
November 8th Regina Tiedemann is
diagnosed with breast cancer and two
days later on the 10th
Ulrich finds the cave that will later
take him to 1953 and is of
eventual attempted murder of young Helga
November 12th also happens to be the
final episode of season one where
middle-aged Jonas ends up closing the
wormhole in the cave seven months later
in June of 2020 we get into many of the
events of season 2 special agent
Claussen is assigned to windin after no
progress has been made on the missing
children cases Alexander te'devan
knowing that plant is about to be
decommissioned has the barrels of toxic
waste buried and covered in concrete
Jonas tells Hannah is her son and takes
her to 1987 where she sees Mikkel has
been adopted by eNOS Claudius Caesar
grown-up daughter Regina dying of cancer
and Katarina finds out that Mikkel grew
up in the 80s and she begins her journey
of trying to get to the 80s to save her
son and husband five days into Klaus ins
investigation he arrests alexander for
identity theft of his brother who went
missing in 1986 the next day yonas holds
Marta at gunpoint and locks her in the
bunker because he can't bear the thought
of her dying in the pending apocalypse
but this doesn't really work because she
later escapes when Peter and Elizabeth
come into the bunker for safety Claussen
gets a search warrant to dig up the
toxic waste and Marta who has gone back
to younger Jonas is shot by Adam this
date is where things get very
complicated because three different
events occur here that alter time in
three different directions if you've
seen my ending explained video for
season 3 you'll know this particular
moment is called a switch point where
cause and effect stop for a brief moment
and things can be changed one outcome we
see is that Marta shot and alternate
Marta comes in and saves yonis outcome
two is Marta is shot but no one comes to
save Jonas and outcome three is Marta is
shot but a different Adam returns and
takes yonas to fulfill his destiny of
stopping the car crash in 1971 this is
also the date where Charlotte is
transported into the future when she
sees Elisabeth through the portal fast
forward three months to September 22nd
2020 where were in full post-apocalypse
mode
Claudia looks after her cancer stricken
daughter while Peter and Elizabeth
search for Charlotte and Francesca two
days later Peter will die trying to save
his daughter paving the way for Noah to
become
figure in Elizabeth's life we don't have
an exact date for this but somewhere
around here we have the final scene of
the series which takes place in the
origin timeline this is Regina's dinner
party where Hannah and Waller have a
baby they decide to name Jonas it's the
world that occurs if town house never
made his time machine in 2021 Elizabeth
and Noah dig out the passage in the
windin caves
two years later yonas and Claudia try to
get the god particle to work but after
several failed attempts yonas tries to
kill himself but is saved by Noah he
learns that even if he turns the gun on
himself fate won't allow him to die
because an older version of himself Adam
is still alive how could Adam still be
alive in the future if Jonas killed
himself in the past it's one of darks
many paradoxes in 2040 Claudia kills the
alternate version of herself in order to
begin orchestrating her plan to end the
not for good the next year Elizabeth
gives birth to baby Charlotte who is
later stolen by older Charlotte and
Elizabeth's so she can be brought to
1971 and given to a tan house this is
all part of Adams plan to ensure
everything goes the way it's supposed to
in 2050 two of the alternate timeline
Jonas and alternate Marta meet middle
age Marta after Jonas decides to bring
her to Eve in his search for answers the
next day bartosh who was assigned with
picking up Marta before she goes to save
yonus at the end of season two brings
her to Eve who slashes her face as a
reminder of which side she's on that's
when Eve shows Marta her son and
instructs Marta to kill yonus because if
she doesn't her child will die that's
why way back in 2020 we had that scene
where Marta kills Jonas we're kind of
coming full circle here November 12 2050
in the future at the end of season 1 and
it isn't until 7 months later in June of
2050 that he finds the god particle in
the abandoned nuclear plant
Jonas finds out he needs fuel to
stabilize it but is caught in the dead
zone and sentenced to death
adult Elizabeth ends up shooting down
the Rope at the last minute allowing
yonas to go back to the god particle
where he successfully travels to 1921 in
September of 2015 that the Marta who
saved yonas at the end of season 2 and
left a middle-aged Onis in a teen
88 is working with Adam only to be
betrayed by him and captured he tells
her that she's pregnant and inside her
is the origin which must be destroyed in
order to end this endless cycle of pain
and suffering and now we have the
furthest entry in the dark saga
September 25th 2015 3 this is the day
Adams attempt at killing Marta is
unsuccessful and he learns he's been
tricked by Claudia eventually joining
her side to unite his younger self and
Marta to save townhouses family and
avoid the splitting of the origin world
in two wow that was a lot I know I
couldn't get everything but I hope this
was a fun video for you guys and please
make sure to LIKE and subscribe as I
come up with tons of theory and timeline
videos for more bat takes follow me on
twitter at ding story YT until next time
remember daddy loves you very much